montana big sky country
the treasure state people got a lot of
names for it I just call it home empty
in my whole life still amazed at how
beautiful it is maybe that's what
blinded us to how ugly the people were
getting you don't understand no one took
these groups seriously
they were different religious militant
it was a goddamn cult
LOB's is upon us my children they
started buying up every fun for miles
than the radio station not long after
that they even have the [ __ ] cops
their own sovereign religious state
built right here under our noses
ain't no one coming to help us this
government can't do [ __ ] we're on our
own people don't want to believe groups
like this exist people are scared man
some who wish to harm us some wish to
destroy all the way of built here
together some betrayals
we don't know what he's capable their
leader Joseph seed they call him the
father and those in the outside world
are blind they do not believe
have no faith
but I will make them see
hey rookie Rookie wastin your time
there's no signal I'm crossing over the
henbane now crazy [ __ ] Jesus
we're officially in Peggy country how
much longer I'm just long enough for you
to change your mind so I can turn this
bird around you want me to ignore his
federal warrant Sheriff
no sir I want you to understand the
reality of this situation
Joseph seed he's not a man to be for
folks with we've had run-ins with it
before they haven't always gone our way
just sometimes sometimes it's best to
leave well enough alone yeah well we
have laws for a reason sheriff and
Joseph seeds gonna learn that
Pratt open a call with dispatched n4y
doors to dispatch over
we'll approach the compound Nancy we are
unfortunately still trying to talk some
sense another friend Marshall Oh
therefore over and out maybe we should
have brought an aunty along with us
instead of a Probie miss Peggy's
wouldn't [ __ ] with her Pratt
where'd he keep calling Peggy's project
and even escape
Det Peggy's is what the locals call no
he started off almost a few years back
now they are armed to the teeth now
they're looking for a fight
he's scared Sheriff
we're here compounds just below
this is a bad idea
last chance Marshall
[Applause]
Roger that
dispatch you still there you don't hear
from us in 15 minutes send everyone call
the goddamn National Guard if you have
to or
let me do the tongue
okay
stay sharp
can be in the church stick close
roasted Spooky's rook
pick up stay calm everyone let's go
about your business this doesn't concern
like this everything's financing it's
just fun
Jesus Christ you're wearing badges
aren't you
yeah the data was the crashes myself
here they'll respect the nine-millimeter
we do this we do it my way quietly find
another door key on me you just not to
do anything stupid relax Sheriff you're
about to get your name in the paper
you'll be fine
something is coming you can feel came
creeping over the edge and there will be
a reckoning
that is why let's start the project
because we know what happens next they
will come they will try to take from us
take our guns take our freedom take our
faith we will not let them Sheriff we
will not let their greed or the
immorality or their to pray but he hurt
us anymore sure there will be no more
suffering on fungus Joseph see I have a
warrant issued for your arrest on the
suspicion of kidnapping with the intent
to harm now I want you to step forward
and keep your hands where I can see them
there they are locusts in our garden see
they've come for me they've come to take
me away from you
they've come to destroy all the we fail
[Applause]
we knew this moment would come we've
prepared for go-go
God will not let them take me
to first seal and I heard as it were the
noise of thunder one of the four beasts
saying come and see
step and I saw and behold it was white
horse
[Music]
and hell followed with him
brookey cuff this son of a [ __ ]
God will not let you take me
rook put the cuffs on
sometimes the best thing to do
is to walk away
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
Marshall take point one right on it
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we can't keep up
I am a federal marshal I'm ordering you
to stand back
[Music]
Bly
[Applause]
[Music]